unfortunately as we all know las vegas
is all too familiar with mass shootings
one october is still the deadliest in
the country
we spoke to metro sheriff joe lombardo
this morning about the recent attacks
and how metro responds here following
those tragedies
what we learned from those type of
crimes are there's copycats
or there's people that are motivated by
what somebody else does
and so we we motivate our troops we make
them aware through the intelligence
sources
and then we respond to the specific
areas that we have concerns with
or some areas that we may be receiving
threats for
so an example would be when we had the
theater shootings in colorado
we did a constant omnipresence
within those facilities uh for quite
some time and similar to what occurred
with the asian community here recently
um we've had an increase of omnipresence
of officers so
the the community feels comfortable uh
that the police department's paying
attention of course those horrible
shootings in atlanta were just last week
if you have a question for sheriff joe
lombardo you can send it to us on our
website it's eight newsnow dot com
the sheriff joins us every wednesday
morning on good day las vegas at 6
30.